have we ever had anybody that's been
famous
slightly famous
that was ever possessed that needed an
exorcist exorcism done on them
i can't think of anyone that's wow
why
like let me explain what i mean by like
a
basketball player baseball player
an actor a politician a military leader
anybody that was
somebody of influence
why haven't they ever why if the devil
is
doing what he's doing why isn't he going
and possessing those guys from
preventing them
from maybe there's a you know
maybe there's somebody that's can make a
why is he going after people that we
don't know regular folk can i follow up
on that real quick i actually want to
hear that answer yeah and then you can
follow
what you hear from these famous people
is they've sold their soul to the devil
yeah that's how they got famous and so
to your point yeah i'd like to hear his
response
yeah because again i think it would be
that
somebody would have to come public first
of all they would have to want to
share their story there could be the
stigma that people will think that
they're
not in their right mind and then maybe
they're going to lose their
whatever position the power prestige
that they have so they may not be
willing to step forward
goes back to the question again so why
does the average joe get possessed but
somebody that's more prominent doesn't
and the key would be whether or not
somebody is truly seeking help
that's the key thing whether or not
somebody's famous whether or not they're
not famous
again i don't go out and search for
people that i believe to be able but if
the spirit gets a hold of you do you
have any control so if you even if
you're famous and powerful if the spirit
gets a hold of you mean to tell me
you're more powerful than the spirit
no you know what i'm saying it depends
on the degree that one's dealing with
the demonic because something of the
person always remains free that's why
even somebody that's possessed could ask
for help
it's not total there is something that's
called a perfect possession
where somebody takes their free will and
they unite their free will completely
with the demonic so there never would be
any manifestations then the fact that
there are manifestations would indicate
that there's still an internal battle
there's still a struggle that's taking
place
but it could be that somebody is
possessed but because they've resigned
their free will to the will of the devil
there is no manifestation there's no
battle to take place
yeah but if if the devil is so strong
why is he why does he have a hard time
getting a hold of
other people that are influencers
why why why and by the way to say that
maybe we don't know about it when you're
famous we know all your business you
know the people that get
criticism is fame like you know some
people want to go i'd love to go out
there and become successful like that
guy or this guy or that guy and i'd love
to have you know be a basketball player
and get all the fame i'd love to be a
hollywood star but the moment you go
there all your business is everyone's
business hey this person's brother did
this
patrick mahomes brother went through
this
tom brady's going through this in his
you know issue that's why he took a
break that person is going through this
i mean
because even when you're you can't talk
by yourself somebody's going to leak
something you know i told a friend of
mine one time i said i said when i when
you and i talk about my personal life do
you tell your wife
you said it's my wife i'm married to her
so you can't tell your tell my business
to your wife why because even if you
tell your wife what if you and your wife
get a divorce one day what's her loyalty
to my secrets of my life that i shared
with you and the struggles that i have
there is no loyalty so that has to stay
between you and i he said that totally
makes sense and it finally made sense
i'm like okay great so even if you're
famous sometimes your biggest fear is
who do i confide in but eventually
you're going to confide in somebody and
that person is going to leak you this is
why they'll say such and such has agreed
to three-year contract extension
okay this person has just gone
so i don't know why people who are more
because if let's just say you have to
think about the devil right if you are
the devil
you go take somebody
that's got influence over what
one person or nobody why would you do
that
then you're a small thinker
so if if we are saying the devil is as
power which by the way i do believe
i do believe if you wrestle with them
you better have somebody backing you up
i do believe that
but my interpretation is a different
interpretation
my interpretation is an exorcism
interpretation
my interpretation is for him to convince
you
you know for for people sometimes to
believe that they don't need help they
don't need faith they don't need a
higher power to back them up i believe
for what i want to do in my life i need
faith i need i need backing for somebody
to back me up i want favor
i want favor at the highest level
because
i do think there's going to be
challenges i do think there's going to
be people that are going to get in the
way and i do believe sometimes maybe if
there is a devil he uses people to get
in the way of you doing something big
but it's not the devil of
you know things like this because if the
devil is really doing this
he should target players and influencers
to get them to drop because if they drop
then
he wins at a higher level yeah and it
could be that people are dealing with
the demonic they're just not aware of it
because ultimately the devil doesn't
want to be
in the spotlight he prefers to work in
the shadows if you will but you're a
bully if you're going after helpless
people like what outcome do you have of
going after annelise michelle like what
did you do with that
like let's play the game and go in the
devil's conference room with 12 other
masters and you know advisors sitting
there okay let's go after annelise
michelle what's your outcome what a what
a week
you know how much weakness you're
showing if you're going after a helpless
16 year old kid what do you think you
did you didn't do anything special but
then see then that that's a great point
then the devil is showing his true
character
so the devil believes he's doing
something that's advancing his agenda
his kingdom but ultimately all that ends
up doing is advancing the kingdom of god
then maybe we shouldn't be afraid of the
guy which never no one should ever be
afraid of the devil because because
because the point then becomes he's not
as strong as you think he is
it's through your imagination that if
you let your imagination let loose
that's where he destroys you
because he makes you believe there's a
thousand people around the corner that
got his back that will fight you he's by
himself
okay if that's the argument because
i think sometimes the imagination gets
people to
and that and the demonic plays on a
person's memory and imagination right
that was trying to get into your head
and i think in the role of an exorcism
the goal is to get the devil out of your
head and to get god into your head
because yeah the devil there's nothing
to fear
you know a lot of people will watch the
videos of annelise michelle and you know
they're going to be terrified by all of
that but again they shouldn't be so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]